สวัสดีค่ะครูปุ๊กสวัสดีค่ะครูบีแล้วก็
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนค่ะค่ะสวัสดีนัก
เรียนทุกคนเช่นกันค่ะค่ะแล้วก็ขอต้อนรับ
ทุกคนนะคะเข้าสู่ห้องเรียนภาษาไทยห้อง
เรียน comprehensible ไยค่ะอืวันนี้ดีใจ
มากนะคะได้มาเจอครูปุ๊กหลังจากไม่ได้เจอ
กันนานเลยตั้งแต่ปีที่แล้วค่ะ
อ้านานมากเลยเนาะนานใช่เพราะว่าตอนเนี้ย
วันนี้เนี่ยเป็นวันอะไรแล้วคะครูปุ๊กวัน
นี้เนี่ยเป็นวันศุกร์แล้วค่ะเห็นมั้ยเรา
ไม่เจอกันหลายอาทิตย์เหมือนกันนะครูบีมา
เจอกันวันศุกร์แล้วก็เป็นวันที่เท่าไหร่
คะวันนี้วันที่ 19 ค่ะ
นะเดือนอะไรคะเดือนมกราคมค่ะนะเป็นเดือน
ที่ 1 นะคะนะปีพ.ศล่ะคะปีพ.ศ
2567 ค่ะนะปีค.ศล่ะคะปีค.ศ
2024 ค่ะนะวันนี้วันศุกร์ที่ 19 เดือน
มกราคมปีพ.ศ
2567 ปีค.ศ 2024 ค่ะครูบีเราไม่ได้เจอ
กันนานมากเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยวันนี้เนี่ยมา
เจอกันเนี่ยครูปุ๊กเนี่ย
อยากจะชวนครูบีค่ะอืชวนครูบีใชเดี๋ยวๆนะ
คะวันนี้เนี่ยเป็นวันศุกร์ใช่มั้ยอ่าเรา
นัดเจอกันค่ะในคลิปวีีดีโอนัดเจอกันแล้ว
ครูปุ๊กก็อยากจะนัดเจอครูบีแล้วก็อยากจะ
ชวนครูบีชวนไปไหนคะชวนไปเที่ยวตลาดนัดรถ
ไฟตลาดนัดกลางคืนตลาดนัดอุเยอะเลยค่ะครู
ปุ๊กเห็นในในนะใน YouTube อย่างเงี้ยพว่า
อ๋อจริงๆแล้วก็อยู่บางตลาดนัดเนี่ยบางที่
เนี่ยอยู่ใกล้ๆบ้านครูปุ๊กด้วยอืโอถ้าพูด
ถึงตลาดนัดตอนกลางคืนเนี่ยในกรุงเทพฯมี
เยอะมากนะครูปุ๊กใช่แล้วก็ครูบีนชอบไป
เดินนะคะจริงๆเนี่ยตลาดนัดเนี่ยนะนัก
เรียนอาจจะงงๆเอ๊ะทำไมมีมีตลาดแล้วยังมี
ตลาดนัดอีกนะเรามีตลาดที่ติดแอร์ก็คือ
ซุปเปอร์มาร์เก็ตใช่มั้ยใช่ค่ะแต่เราก็มี
ตลาดแบบคนไทยเนาะตลาดสดนะจะขายผักขายปลา
ขายขายหลายๆอย่างเนตลาดก็จะใหญ่มากนะแต่
ว่าเราก็จะมีตามหมู่บ้านนะอมีบ้านๆบๆๆคน
หลายเยอะๆอยู่ด้วยกันเนาะอาจจะไกลจากตลาด
ตลาดสดอืนะแล้วก็ไกลจากซุปเปอร์มาร์เก็ต
เา้าก็จะมีตลาดที่เราเปิดตอนกลางคืนนะ
ซึ่งตลาดอันเนี้ยเนาะอาจจะเปิดบางที่อาจ
จะเปิดตลาดนัดเนี่ยอาจจะเปิดสักตอนเย็นๆ
นะอาจจะตั้งแต่ 15:00 นบางที่อาจจะเปิด
15:00 นหรือว่า 1600 น 17 นนะก็แบบคนก็
เริ่มเอาของมาวางวางๆาแล้วก็ขายสสมัยก่อน
นะครูบีบ้านครูปุ๊กเนี่ยเป็นหมู่บ้านเน
นักเรียนหมู่บ้านก็คือมีบ้านๆๆหลายๆหลัง
นะแล้วก็เขามีตลาดที่เมื่อก่อนไม่มีตลาด
แล้วก็เลยมีคนคิดอ้าจัดเป็นตลาดนัดอืนะ
นัดแม่ค้าพ่อค้าคนขายของเนี่ยมารวมกันนะ
มีหลายๆคนที่ขายนะขายอะไรขายผักขายปลาขาย
นะหมูขายไก่ขายอะไรเยอะแยะนะขายอาหารด้วย
แล้วเขาก็นัดกันว่าวันพุธนะทุกวันพุธ
เนี่ยมาเจอกันนะเค้าก็จะมีที่สำหรับขาย
แบ่งเป็นล็อคล็อกล็เนนะขนาดไม่ใหญ่ค่ะ
ขนาดเล็กๆนะอ๋อคือคือนัดกันว่าวันวันอะไร
ใช่มั้ยสมมุติครูบีอยากขายเสื้อผ้าครู
ปุ๊กอยากขายผลไม้อ่าบางคนอยากขายอาหารก็
คือจะนัดเลยว่าวันพุธมาเจอกันที่นี่ใช่
เพราะว่าบ้านครูปุ๊กเนี่ยเมื่อก่อนมีตลาด
นัดแค่อาทิตย์ละ 1 วันค่ะนะก็คือวันพุธ
ทุกวันพุธเนี่ยนะแม่ค้าพ่อค้าที่ขายของ
เนาะแม่ค้าก็คือผู้หญิงที่ขายของนะเอ่อ
พ่อค้าก็คือผู้ชายที่ขายของนะแล้วก็ใช่
ค่ะแล้วก็มาเจอกันบอกว่าทุกวันพุธนะนะมา
ที่หมู่บ้านครูปุ๊กเนี่ยแหละมีหมู่บ้านนะ
หมู่บ้านชื่อธนศิลป์เนาะเาก็จะมารวมกัน
ค่ะโอ๊ยแต่เมื่อก่อนนะแบบนี้เลยค่ะครูบี
เห็นมมีพ่อค้าคนนี้ก็ขายผักกับผลไม้อ่า
แม่ค้าก็คือผู้หญิงเนี่ยเห็นมั้ยขายผลไม้
มีส้มมีแอปเปิ้ลแล้วตรงนี้มีขายปลาเห็น
มั้ยคะมีขายผักก็คือนัดมาเจอกันก็จะมีคน
เนี่ยมาขายของแบบเนี้ยเยอะเลยใช่ค่ะก็จะ
มีของที่เหมือนกันแล้วก็ไม่เหมือนกันนะ
ใครอยากมาขายก็มาเช่าที่นะก็จะเป็นช่วง
เวลากตั้งแต่ 15 นอย่างเงี้ยค่ะไปจนถึง
แบบแล้วแต่บางที่เนาะบางที่ก็ 20:00 น
21:00 นนะอก็บางที่อาจจะไปถึง 2:00 นก็
มีนะแต่ครูปุ๊กเนี่ยก็ดึกก็ไม่มีคคนแล้ว
ก็เแค่ประมาณสัก 20:00 นก็เสร็จแล้วค่ะอ
อันนี้เป็นตลาดนัดในหมู่บ้านเขาก็จะเปิด
เร็วหน่อยเนาะเพราะว่าอย่างในหมู่บ้าน
เนี่ยก็ไม่ต้องเปิดดึกมากนะคะเพราะว่าอ่า
ซัก 15 น 16:00 นคือสามารถไปเดินซื้อของ
ได้แล้วใช่มั้ยคะใช่ค่ะ 15:00 นเนี่ยก็
พ่อค้าแม่ค้าก็มาตั้งของกันแล้วแล้วก็
เพราะว่าคนที่จะไปซื้อเนี่ยก็จะซื้อไปทำ
อาหารเนาะนะเพื่อกินตอนเย็นนะอ่าแต่ถ้า
ใครไม่อยากไปซื้ออาหารเห็นมั้ยคะมีของ
เล่นเด็กๆมีตุ๊กตามีเสื้อผ้าใช่ค่ะตลาด
นัดมีหลายๆอย่างให้เราเลือกซื้อได้เลยใช่
ถูกต้องค่ะครูบีเห็นมยเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ย
ตลาดนัดเนี่ยก็เลยนัดกันมานะแม่ค้าพ่อค้า
เนี่ยนัดกันมาเพื่อขายของแล้วก็คนที่ใน
หมู่บ้านก็จะไปซื้อของใช่มั้ยเราก็จะเป็น
ลูกค้านะจัเงินค่ะซื้อของนะแล้วต่อมานะ
ครูบีอือวันพุธอย่างเดียวเนี่ยโอ้โหคน
เยอะมากนะแม่ค้าพ่อค้าก็เยอะอืคนซื้อก็
เยอะอพ่อค้าแม่ค้าก็เลยบอกว่าอย่างงั้น
นัดกันเพิ่มดีกว่าเอาวันพุวันเดียวไม่
โอเคเออใช่ก็เลยนัดกันวันเสาร์อีก 1 วัน
เป็นอาทิตย์นึงเนี่ยมาจัดตลาดนัดเนี่ย 2
วันวันพุธกับวันเสาร์อ๋อถ้าไปหมู่บ้านของ
ครูปุ๊กเนี่ยก็จะรู้เลยว่าวันพุธจะมีตลาด
นัดวันเสาร์ก็จะมีตลาดนัด
เออคนก็จะรอไปซื้อของใช่มั้ยคะใช่นะแต่พอ
ขายดีมากๆค่ะครูบีตอนนี้ไม่ต้องนัดด้วย
ค่ะขายทุกวันค่ะ
อ้าวจริงๆครูบีคิดว่าเออตามหมู่บ้านเนี่ย
มันเล็กๆใช่มยคนอาจจะไปซื้อของเนี่ยก็ไม่
เยอะตลาดคนที่มามามานัดเจอกันเนี่ยเพื่อ
ขายของที่เราเรียกว่าตลาดนัดเนี่ยก็เลยมี
แค่ 1 อาทิตย์ 2 วันนะคะมีนิดหน่อยเพราะ
ว่าอาจจะขายของทุกวันขายไม่ได้ไงก็ 1
อาทิตย์ 2 วันเนี่ยเอออาจจะขายได้ขายดี
อ่าแต่ตอนนี้มีทุกวันเพราะว่าขายดีมากใช่
ค่ะแล้วก็หมู่บ้านครูปุ๊เป็นหมู่บ้านใหญ่
ค่ะนะมีบ้านอาจจะเป็นร้หลังคาเรือนหรือ
ว่ารหลังใช่มั้ยก็เลยแบบมันมันก็เลยมีคน
ที่มาขายแล้วขายดีก็เลยอยากมาอีกมาอีกก็
เลยตอนนี้อยู่ทุกวันแล้วค่ะตอนนี้นัดแค่
เวลาค่ะนัดว่าตลาดนัดวันนี้เปิดกี่โมงอ่า
บ 3 นถึงกี่โมงใช่มเออใช่นะแต่ถ้าเป็น
ตลาดนัดที่
แบบแบบตลาดนั้นในหมู่บ้านครูปุ๊กเนี่ยมัน
ปิดเร็วไงคะอืใช่นะบางคนเนี่ยยังกลับไม่
ถึงบ้านเลยค่ะ 20:00 นตลาดนัดปิดแล้วนะก็
เลยทำให้แบบบางที่เก็เลยคิดไงครูบีว่าเอ๊
นะเพราะว่าอย่างคนที่ไปทำงานกว่าจะกลับ
เนอะก็ดึกแล้วเพราะว่ารถติดอืแล้วก็คนที่
เป็นนักศึกษาเรียนมหาวิทยาลัยเนี่ยเรียน
เสร็จเนี่ยก็ค่ำแล้วเนาะนมันก็เย็นแล้ว
อ่ะนะเขาก็อยากเจอเพื่อนอยากไปดื่มไปกิน
ไปเที่ยวไปช้อปปิ้งอืนะมันก็เลยเกิดตลาด
นัดตอนกลางคืนขึ้นมาไง
อืนะนี่แหละก็กลายเป็นว่าตอนนี้คน
กรุงเทพฯเนี่ยก็ชอบไปเดินตลาดนัดตอนกลาง
คืนไงค่ะนะอันนี้ไม่ต้องพ่อค้าแม่ค้านัด
กันแล้วค่ะคนที่จะไปเนี่ยต้องนัดกันค่ะ
อย่างครูปุ๊กก็จะมานัดกับครูบีเนี่ยล่ะ
ค่ะว่าคืนเนี้ยไปมั้ยคะวันนี้วัน
ศุกร์
อ่าไปเอออยากไปนักนักเรียนคะครูปุ๊กเนี่ย
ขับรถไม่เป็นค่ะนะครูบีเเนี่ยมีรถค่ะครู
บีขับรถเป็นครูปุ๊ก็เลยชวนครูบีค่ะอ่า
เพราะว่าเดี๋ยวครูบีก็จะขับรถไปบ้านครู
ปุ๊กแล้วก็รับครูปุ๊กไปตลาดนัดกลางคืนใน
กรุงเทพฯเพราะว่าไปตลาดนัดเนี่ยครูปุ๊ก
ไม่อยากนั่งรถไฟฟ้ารถไฟฟ้า MRT รถแท็กซี่
เพราะว่าครูปุ๊กชอบช้อปปิ้งใช่มั้ยคะ
อ๋อเพราะว่า MRT  BTS เนี่ยบางทีไม่ถึง
ตลาดค่ะอนะถ้าตลาดอย่างใกล้ๆบ้านครูปุ๊ก
เนี่ยสัก 3 กมอืก็ไม่มี MRT รถใต้ดินเนาะ
รถไฟใต้ดินไม่มีนะ BTS ไม่มีนะอต้องขับรถ
หรือนั่งแท็กซี่ใช่มั้ยถูกต้องค่ะนะอืแต่
ถ้าไม่มีเพื่อนไงครูบีถ้าไปแท็กซี่อืไป
กับครูบีเเนี่ยมีเพื่อนด้วยมีโชเฟอร์อุ้ย
คนขับรถด้วยออให้ครูบีเป็นโชเฟอร์เป็นคน
ขับรถใช่มั้ยขับรถโอครูปุ๊กก็เป็น V  VIP
นะเอออืกูปุกนั่งสบายนะคะแล้วก็ไปตลาดนัด
แน่นอนเชื่อว่านอกจากเราจะไปกินแล้วเราก็
ต้องไปซื้อของซื้อของกินกลับบ้านได้ด้วย
เออมีรถรถไงโอเอาใส่รถกลับมาที่บ้านอืใช่
ค่ะแล้วก็เราเนี่ยโหตลาดนัดแต่ละที่นะมี
ของขายเยอะมากๆเลยไม่ว่าจะไปดูค่ะของกิน
ของใช้นะของกินก็คือกินได้อืของใช้เนี่ย
ต้องใช้อย่างเสื้อผ้าเนี่ยกินไม่ได้ก็ใช้
ได้บางอย่างกินก็ได้ใช้ก็ได้ด้วยนะอย่าง
เชเป็นของใช้ที่เกี่ยวกับเทคโนโลยีเนาะ
อ่าบีก็อันนี้ก็ได้มาจากตลาดนัดนะคะน่า
รักมอืเอาไว้วาง
โทรศัพท์น่ารักดู YouTube นะคะอ่าเนี่ย
วางได้คะอันนี้ก็ซื้อมาจากตลาดนัดนะเป็น
ตลาดนัดกันอ๋อน่ารักค่ะครูบียืดได้ด้วย
ใช่นะพับเก็บได้ยืดอยืดออกค่ะเรายืดออก
ได้เราเอาไว้แบบตั้งโทรศัพท์แล้วก็เซลฟี่
ได้นะคะนี่เห็นมยถ่ายวีีดีโอตัวเองก็ได้
นะ
สวยเพราะว่าใช้ฟิลเตอร์สวยทุกทุกรูปนะ
คะดีมากเทคโนโลยีนี่ช่วยได้ค่ะงั้นเดี๋ยว
ครูบุ๊กลองพาไปดูตลาดนัดที่ใกล้ๆบ้านครู
ปุ๊กนะได้ค่ะเพราะว่าตลาดนัดเนี่ยแต่ละ
ที่ก็จะมีของขายไม่เหมือนกันเดี๋ยวเราไป
ดูว่าเนี่ยที่ครูปุ๊งให้ดูเนี่ยเขาขาย
อะไรบ้างนะคะโอนี่เห็นมอันนี้ชื่อว่าตลาด
นัดเรียบด่วนอือุยดังนะมีชื่อเสียงใช่ค่ะ
ซุปเปอร์สตาร์ไทยมีนักร้องไทยนะคนที่แบบ
มีชื่อเสียงเี่ไปเดินช้อปปิ้งเยอะมากไป
ซื้อของใช่หรือบางบางคนอาจจะเป็นพ่อค้า
หรือแม่ค้าเองเลยเอาของมาขายนะอืนะนี่ไง
แม่ข้าขายอะไรคะ
เนี่ยดูซิดูบีดูเค้าขายอะไรกันบ้างอ่าอัน
นี้ครูบีดูในรูปเนี่ยก็อาจจะเป็นของใช้
ค่ะเอาไว้ใช้นะคะไม่ใช่อาหารนะไม่ใช่ของ
กินกินไม่ได้ค่ะน่าจะเป็นพวกเครื่องหนัง
เนบีใช่มั้ยอาจจะซื้อสำหรับเอาไว้ใส่รถ
หรืออาจจะเป็นสำหรับรถที่เราขับหรือว่ารถ
ที่สำหรับบางคนมีลูกเนาะอาจจะเป็นพวกเบาะ
พวกพวกของใช้นะที่เป็นอุปกรณ์อยู่ในรถก็
ได้นะคะเพราะว่ามันภาพมันเอ่อเป็นตอนกลาง
คืนนะคะมีทุกอย่างเลยอันนี้เป็นของใช้หมด
นะคะไหนลองเลื่อนลงมานี่อ่าอันนี้ค่ะอ่า
อันนี้ก็จะเป็นพวกเสื้อที่เขาแบบว่าเป็น
ลายเห็นมั้ยมีลายดอกไม้เป็นเสื้อแฟชั่น
เนาะมีหมวกมีเสื้อนะคะนี่เลยค่ะใกล้
สงกรานต์เนี่ยอันนี้ค่ะต้องใส่ลายดอกไม้
ค่ะนะใช่นะเป็นเสื้อผ้าแฟชั่นแล้วก็ราคา
ไม่แพงนะคะ
อือนะส่วนฝั่งนู้นก็จะเป็นพวกกระเป๋า
สตางค์นะคะอ่ามีเงินเยอะก็ซื้อเยอะๆนะคะ
ก็ซื้อใบใหญ่ค่ะโอเหรอค่ะมีเงินน้อยก็เอา
ใบเล็กๆค่ะอุ๊ยเดี๋ยวนี้เค้าไม่ค่อยพก
เงินสดแล้วค่ะไม่ค่อยมีเงินเท่าไหร่ใช้นะ
โทรศัพท์เมีแอปพลิเคชันแล้วก็โอนเงินแต่
ก็ต้องมีกระเป๋าสตางค์ไงค่ะเอาไว้ใส่บัตร
เครดิตไงครูปุ๊กอ่าใช่อ้าต้องมีค่ะเพราะ
ว่ามันจะได้ดูสวยอ่านี่ค่ะนี่ค่ะ
โอใหญใหญ่มากค่ะเนี่ยแหละแถวบ้านครูปุ๊ก
เองใกล้ๆนะก็เลยจะมานัดครูบีไงคะเห็นมั้ย
โูแบบนี้นะครูปุ๊กเดินซื้อของเสร็จแล้วก็
เมื่อยขาไงก็ต้องไปหาอาหารกินเนาะใช่เห็น
มยแล้วก็จริงๆเขาคก็มีโซนของอาหารใช่มั้ย
ครูบีนะมีดื่มมั้ยมีดื่มมั้ยมีสิค่ะอ่าก็
มีเป็นพวกเครื่องดื่มก็มีนะคะอ่ะเดี๋ยว
อ่าครูบีจะเปิดให้ดูเนาะออืได้ค่ะนะเพราะ
ว่าเราสามารถไปนั่งดื่มได้นะครูปุ๊กใช่
ค่ะคือเครื่องดื่มก็จะมีทั้งแบบมี
แอลกอฮอล์ไม่มีแอลกอฮอล์เนาะใช่นะคือคุณ
สามารถไปนั่งดื่มได้นะคะเป็นพวกเครื่อง
ดื่มที่มีแอลกอฮอล์ก็จะเป็นเหล้าเป็น
เบียร์ใช่มยออ่าแต่ถ้าเครื่องดื่มที่ไม่
มีแอลกอฮอล์ก็จะเป็นพวกน้ำผลไม้อืกาแฟนะ
คะน้ำผลไม้ปั่น
เออนะอันนี้ก็จะเป็นแบบพวกอ่ารร้านนั่ง
ดื่มนะเราสามารถเลือกดื่มได้เนาะอ่ามันจะ
มี 2 แบบนะครูปุ๊กอ้าแบบไหนบ้างคะครูบีก็
คือว่าเวลาที่เราเดินซื้อของใช่มอ่ะอย่าง
ให้ดูอันนี้ครูปุ๊กไปเดินดูเสื้อผ้า
แฟชั่นเสร็จใช่มั้ยคะใช่ค่ะอุุก็เหนื่อย
เนาะเหนื่อยเนี่ยก็ไปนวดเอาดี
ค่ะไปนวดเสร็จแล้วเนี่ยครูปุ๊กเอ้ออยาก
ดื่มน้ำอ่านี้ก็จะมีโอ้โหมีเค้กมีกาแฟมี
น้ำผลไม้หรือเป็นอาหารเห็นมก็จะมีทั้ง
แอลกอฮอล์แลไม่มีแอลกอฮอล์
อ่าโอ้โหนี่ครูบีเ้าน่าจะมีแบบนวดไปด้วย
กินไปด้วยดื่มไปด้วยได้นะร้านนวดเนี่ยเขา
จะไม่เสิร์ฟค่ะไม่เสิร์ฟเครื่องดื่มนะคะ
เพราะว่าเวลาเรานวดเนี่ยเราจะไม่กิน
เดี๋ยวแบบมันต้องแบบสบายๆใช่มยบางคนเนี่ย
เวลานวดไทยใช่มยนวดเท้าเนี่ยก็จะหลับไง
ครูปุ๊กอ๋อเพราะเดินเหนื่อยเดินซื้อของ
เมื่อกี้ครูปุ๊กให้ดูเนี่ยตลาดนัดเรียบ
ทางด่วนเนี่ยมันใหญ่มากมันจะเป็นล็อคใช่
มั้ยเดินกลับมาแล้วก็เดินโอ้โหใช้เวลา
เดินหลายชั่วโมงนะคะใช่เพราะมันใหญ่มากนะ
แล้วก็มีอีกตลาดนึงก็ใกล้บ้านครูปุ๊ก
เหมือนกันครูบีอะไรอ่ะตลาดหัวมุมค่ะอูอัน
นี้ก็ครูบีก็เคยไปนะคะอ่าใหญมากอืใช่มี
แต่ตลาดนัดกลางคืนเใหญ่ๆทั้งนั้นค่ะนะ
แล้วก็มีของขายเยอะเหมือนกันนี่เห็นมยนัก
เรียนนะอ่าอ่าตลาดหัวมุมตลาดหัวมุมอือัน
นี้ติ่งเกาหลีค่ะอ่าคือคนไทยเนี่ยก็จะชอบ
แบบว่าคือเราไปตลาดนัดตอนกลางคืนเนี่ยถ้า
พูดถึงเรื่องอาหารเนี่ยคือใครชอบอาหาร
เกาหลีก็มีอาหารเกาหลีให้กินใครชอบอาหาร
จีนก็มีอาหารจีนใครชอบแบบอาหารฝรั่งเป็น
พวก
สเต็กอเฟรนช์ฟรายใช่มยมันฝรั่งทอดต้องคู่
กัน
เนาะไก่ทอด
เออแต่ไม่ใช่ KFC นะคะอ่ามีให้เลือกกิน
ได้เลยค่ะเห็นมจะเป็นเบอร์เกอร์จะเป็นแบบ
สเต็กเนาะสเต็กหมูสเต็กเนื้อสเต็กไก่
สเต็กปลานะก็มีให้เลือกแล้วก็ถ้าเปิดเป็น
ตลาดนัดแบบเนี้ยจะไม่แพงค่ะไม่แพงอืถูก
นี่คือราคานะราคา
ถูกราคาจะถูกมากใช่มยอืนะอันนี้ก็จะเป็น
ตลาดนัดตอนกลางคืนเหมือนกันตรงด้านหน้า
บางที่ก็จะเห็นมยเป็นลานกว้างๆอันนี้คือ
นั่งกินได้นั่งดื่มได้นะมีอาหารแล้วเราก็
ไปนั่งที่โต๊ะเก้าอี้ได้นะคะก็คือจะนั่ง
ตรงไหนก็ได้เนาะเพราะว่าเราซื้อที่ร้านเน
แล้วก็จ่ายเงินเรียบร้อยแล้วเราก็ยกมากิน
ค่ะมานั่งกินนะโต๊ะไหนว่างก็ไปนั่งเลยค่ะ
นะไม่มีโต๊ะของใครเนาะก็เหมือนเหมื ood
คอร์ตเวลาเราไปกินข้าวเนาะ Food คอร์ใช่
อืเห็นมนี่ครูบีชอบร้านแบบนี้มากครูปุ๊ก
เค้าทำอะไรอ่ะคะครูบีเ้าเห็นมั้ยครูปุ๊ก
จะเห็นว่าเค้าเนี่ยจะขายของที่แบบเป็นงาน
ฝีมือนะมีกระเป๋ามีหมวกเห็นมั้ยคะอ่าแล้ว
ก็มีเป็นพวกเ่าเหมือนกรอบรูปนะคะอาจจะ
กระดาษโตอืผ้าเช็ดหน้าอะไรแบบนี้นะสลับ
เช็ดหน้าอย่างงี้เนาะใช่ก็อาจจะเป็นเนี่ย
ค่ะูปุ๊กเห็นมั้ยคะมีหมวกด้วยใช่เคทำอะไร
อ่ะคะขายหมวกอบางทีหมวกหมวกแกบใช่มเวลา
เราซื้อเนี่ยบางทีเขาก็จะเขียนหรือว่า
เพ้นอถ้าเกิดครูปุ๊กบอกเอออีก 5 วันเป็น
วันเกิดลูกสาวอ่า happ  Birthday ลูกสาว
ลูกสาวครูปุ๊กเนี่ยชอบใส่หมวกครูปุ๊กก็
อาจจะเขียนชื่อใช่มั้ยการตูนอ่าชื่อ Happy
Birthday การ์ตูนอย่างเงี้ยค่ะอ่าก็เพจ
ได้เพนเสื้อได้หรือเป็นหรืออาจออกแบบตัว
หนังสือนะอาจจะตู้น
อืมสวยๆอย่างเงี้ยค่ะใช่นี้ก็จะเป็นพวก
ร้านที่แบบเป็นงานฝีมือเนาะก็คืออาจจะ
เผ็นหมวกวาดหมวกอเป็นตัวหนังสือสวยๆอย่าง
เงี้ยค่ะอ่า
อือหรือว่าบางคนอาจจะแบบไปอยากได้เสื้อ
ผ้าเนาะเสื้อผ้าก็จะมีขายทั้งแบบมือหนึ่ง
มือมือ 2 เนอืนะเป็นแบบมือ 2 ก็มีก็คือมี
คนใช้แล้วแล้วก็ใช้นิดหน่อยแล้วก็รู้สึก
ว่ามันใส่ไม่ได้แล้วอยากเอามาขายก็ขาย
เป็นมือสองได้เนาะใช่นะบางทีก็เป็นพวกงาน
แบบเค้าเรียกอะไร DIY ใช่มั้ยอือ่าพวกเพญ
หมวกสวยๆอย่างเียลายแบบบางทีมีมีหลายแบบ
นะไม่ใช่เฉพาะหมวกแก๊บนะคะครูปุ๊กอาจจะ
เป็นพวกหมวกที่เราเอาไปเดินเที่ยวทะเลก็
ได้ค่ะ
ออ่ะมีมีมีหมวกหลายแบบมากนะคะอ่าอย่างถ้า
เป็นหมวกแก๊บบางคนก็อย่างวัยรุ่นเนี่ย
เขาคก็จะชอบที่มันแบบแฟชั่นใช่มยแต่ถ้า
เป็นผู้หญิงสวยชอบใส่ชุดกระโปรงเ้าก็จะ
ชอบหมวกแบบนี้นี่เก็จะเป็นหมวกแบบเพ้นแบบ
เนี้ยค่ะอ
ออ
นะอันนี้อาจจะเพ้นเองก็ได้นะนะใช่เนาอาจ
จะทำเองนะคะหรือว่าอ่าให้พ่อค้าแม่ค้า
เนี่ยทำให้นะคะนะแล้วเราก็ได้หมวกกลับ
บ้านที่มีไลายมีแฟชั่นไม่เหมือนใครนะอ่า
อย่างครูบีชอบอันนี้ค่ะครูปุ๊กอันไหนคะ
หมวกแก๊บหมวกแก๊บเห็นมยโอ้เ้ออันนี้สวยดี
ครูปุ๊กไปซื้อที่ห้างสรรพสินค้าไม่ได้นะ
คะไม่มีมี
ขายโออันนี้ออกแบบดีค่ะชอบชอบๆเชั่นนะ
เออนี่แหละตลาดนัดรถไฟหรือว่าตลาดนัดกลาง
คืนนะตลาดนัดกลางคืนในกรุงเทพฯเนี่ยก็จะ
มีของให้เลือกเยอะมากนะคะแล้วก็แต่ละที่
ใหญ่ๆทั้งนั้นเลยเนาะครูบีใช่นะคะอือโห
อันนี้เป็นตลาดนัดหัวมุมใช่มยที่กครูปุ๊ก
ให้ดูนะคะใช่ค่ะนะชื่อตลาดนัดหัวมุมนะถ้า
นักเรียนมาแล้วอยากไปเดินเนี่ยนักเรียนก็
ไปเดินได้เห็นมยฬิกาไม่แพงค่ะ 200 บาทค่ะ
โหนาฬิกาโลลกเหรอคะ 200 บาทเออน่าจะโปลก
ค่ะหรือโลเทคก็ไม่
รู้ไม่เป็นไรครูปุ๊กคนไทยบอกว่านาฬิกาสวย
นาฬิกาแฟชั่นจะเป็นโกโป็กก็ซื้อค่ะ 200
บาทนี่อ่าอันนี้ค่ะอันนี้แนะนำเลยคุณผู้
หญิงทั้งหลายเนถ้าเราแบบเอออยากมีเล็บสวย
ๆก็จะมีคนที่เก่งเนอะคนที่ทำเลทำเล็บ
เนี่ยเพราะว่าเล็บเนี่ยเล็กๆเนาะแล้วก็มี
เพ้นลงไปเนี่ยนะก็เลือกลายเา้าก็อาจจะมี
แคตาลอกให้ว่าคุณชอบลายไหนราคาเท่าไหร่
ราคาเอ่อแบบเนี้ยจะไม่ค่อยแพงค่ะนะไม่
เหมือนชอปที่เป็นร้านร้านตลาดนัดจะถูก
กว่าใช่เพราะว่าถ้าคุณไปห้างอ่าไปเ่อ
Terminal  21 ไปสยามพารากอนหรือว่า
เซ็นทรัล World เนี่ยก็จะเป็นร้านที่เป็น
ช็อปที่แบบใหญ่นะมันจะแพงแต่ตลาดนัดกลาง
คืนเนี่ย
10050 บาท 200 บาทก็เพนเล็บได้ค่ะกุุก
เห็นมั้สวยๆเลยค่ะอืนะไม่แพมแล้วถ้าเรา
เดินเหนื่อยแล้วเราก็ต้องเดินหาของกินได้
โอ้โหมันของกินประเทศไทยนี่เยอะมากๆจริงๆ
นะแล้วก็เราเนี่ยอาจจะมารวมกันเนาะทั้ง
ของไทยของฝรั่งของเกาหลีของญี่ปุ่นได้หมด
ค่ะอันนี้แบบนะลูกบอลนะชีสบอลแบบไทมิกใช่
ค่ะนะก็คือเป็นชีส
นะแล้วก็ใส่ในแป้งเนาะเป็นแป้งแบบขนมปัง
อ่ะนะนักเรียนแล้วก็ไปทอดนะกรอบๆพอกัดออก
มาเนี่ยชีส
โอ้โหเยิ้มๆไลๆเหมือนพิซซ่าเนาะใช่อือครู
บี้หิวมคะหิวค่ะอันนี้เป็นหมูทอดกับข้าว
เหนียวเนาะข้าวเหนียวหมูทอดใช่แล้วหมูทอด
น่ากินมากเพราะมันเป็นสีเหลืองๆกำลัง
อร่อยเลยค่ะครูปุ๊กมีข้าวเหนียว 1 ถุก
5 บาทหมูทอดนี่น่าจะ 20 บาทโอ้รูบี้คะ
เดี๋ยวนี้ข้าวเหนียวเนี่ยน่าจะ 10 บาท
แล้วค่ะนะหมูทอดก็ขี่นึงอาจจะ 35 บาท 40
บาทก็โอเคค่ะไม่แพงค่ะชุดนึงก็อาจจะ 50
บาทอืมขวตัวนี้หมูแพงข้าวเหนียวกับหมูทอด
ใช่มั้ยจ่ายไป 50 บาทก็อิ่มอ๊นี่โอ้โหครู
ปุ๊กทำไมนั่งหยุดตรงนีุ้ปุ๊กสวยมากนะคะ
ไม่ใช่สวยมากค่ะจินตนาการคิดๆๆอันนี้มี
นักร้องมาเล่นกีตาร์เอ่าอือมีแบบโอ้โห
เล่นดนตรีแล้วก็ร้องเพลงให้ฟังด้วยนะคะ
อ่าอืนะบางทีเอาจจะมีพวกกลุ่มนักเรียน
แล้วก็จัดมาทำเป็นเหมือนโชว์อืนะโชว์ฝี
มือโชว์เสียงโชว์แล้วก็อาจจะมีกล่องรับ
บริจาคก็ได้นะใช่บางที่ก็มีบางคนโอ้ร้อง
ดีมากก็ให้ 20 บาท 100 บาทเนาะก็อาจจะ
เป็นแบบนักเรียนที่เขาเล่นกีตาร์เก่งร้อง
เพลงเก่งนะก็จะไปตามตลาดนัดกลางคืนอย่าง
นี้ค่ะเพราะเพราะว่าถ้าไปไปโชว์ที่ตลาด
นัดกลางคืนเนี่ยคนเยอะไงครูปุ๊กใช่มั้ย
อ่าโอกาสที่จะได้เงินเนี่ยก็มีเยอะเพราะ
ว่าคนเนี่ยก็จะชอบไปดูไปเดินบางครั้ง
เนี่ยเมื่อกี้มีข้าวเหนียวใช่มั้ยหมูทอด
กินข้าวเหนียวหมูทอดฟังเพลงเอ้อเห็นมั้
เห็นมั้นะเพราะว่าบางที่ก็อาจจะเป็นแบบมี
ดนตรีแล้วก็ให้นั่งดื่มชิลๆนะสบายๆนะค่ะ
นะแล้วก็ตลาดนัดกลางคืนในกรุงเทพฯเนี่ย
คือถ้าเอ่อที่ที่เดินทางสะดวกเนาะก็จะมี
ทางเอ่อตลาดนัดกลางคืนน
กีนตลาดนัดรถไฟครูบีนี่กีนมาเก็ตด้วยตลาด
นัดรถไฟอันนี้น่าจะเป็นตลาดนัดรถไฟ
ศรีนครินทร์นะตอนนี้มี BTS แล้วนะคะครู
ปุ๊กอ่าสายสีเหลืองใช่มยใช่เราสามารถนั่ง
BTS ไปได้นะตรงด้านหน้า sec คอน Square
นะคะก็จะมีสถานี BTS อยู่แต่เป็นสายสี
เหลืองนะคะค่ะแล้วก็อันนี้ก็เป็นตลาดนัด
ใกล้บ้านรูบีค่ะตลาดรถโบราณตะวันนาคือช่
มันจะหมดเวลาแล้วใช่มั้ยใช่ค่ะอนะูบุ๊ก
ให้ดูแบบเจเจกรีนอันนี้ก็เป็นที่ชื่นชอบ
ของหลายๆคนเนาะนะใช่ก็จะอยู่ใกล้ๆจตุจักร
ค่ะอันนี้มีของขายเยอะมากนะมีทั้งเอ่อ
เสื้อผ้าแฟชั่นอาหารแล้วก็มีร้านเครื่อง
ดื่มนะอ่ะอันนี้ก็เป็นตลาดนัดรถไฟ
ศรีนครินทร์นะเห็นมั้ย
มีของเก่าๆด้วยนะพัดลมเก่าๆนี่ค่ะพัดลม
เก่าๆมีเยอะค่ะเดี๋ยวต้องให้นักเรียนมาดู
เองนะบางคนอาจจะได้ของเก่าไปดูเนี่ย
นาฬิกาเก่าๆนะติดผนังอย่างเงี้ยนะมีของ
เก่าน่าสนใจไปนะคะอือันนี้จะเป็นโซนของ
เก่านะคะอืนี้ก็จะเป็นย่านเจริญเอชียชินะ
คะอันนี้คิดว่านักเรียนหลายคนก็จะไปเนาะ
เพราะติดกับแม่น้ำเจ้าพระยานะคะใช่ค่ะอัน
นี้พุพุๆผ่านไปเร็วๆนะอันนี้ก็จะเป็นเป็น
สักถนนข้าวสารค่ะครูปุ๊กอันนี้เข้าโรสนะ
คะนะอันนี้นักเรียนน่าจะชอบกันอืนะแล้วก็
อันนี้ก็จะเป็นตลาดนัดจตุจักรอ่าจตุจักร
ก็มีตลาดกันกลางคืนนะแต่เป็นวันศุกร์วัน
ศุกร์ตอนกลางคืนนะคะมีของให้เลือกแบบราคา
ไม่แพงเลยนักเรียนนะ
นี่โอเคค่ะครูปุ๊กมันเยอะมากอ่าป่ะถ้า
อย่างงั้นเนี่ยให้นักเรียนไปเองดีกว่าแต่
เราเนี่ยเราเนี่ยจะต้องเตรียมตัวแล้วค่ะ
แล้วเราจะไปกันคืนนี้ใช่เพราะว่าคืนนี้
เนี่ยก็มีที่จตุจักรนะคะตลาดนัดกลางคืน
เพราะว่าวันนี้เป็นวันศุกร์นะคะแล้วก็วัน
เสาร์วันอาทิตย์เราก็ไปได้ค่ะตลาดนัด
ศรีนครินทร์นะตลาดนัดเรียบทางด่วนตลาดนัด
หัวหมุมนะเป็นตลาดนัดที่ใกล้ๆบ้านครูปุ๊ก
กับครูบีนะคะแล้วก็ใหญ่มากอืมนะเพราะว่า
เราจะไปซื้อของแล้วก็ไปกินค่ะอืใช่ค่ะนะ
ก็เดี๋ยววันนี้เราต้องลาทุกคนไปก่อนแล้ว
ค่ะเรามาเจอกันคลิปต่อๆไปเนาะว่าเราจะมา
พานักเรียนไปรู้จักอะไรในประเทศไทยนะใช่
วันนี้เราก็พานักเรียนเนี่ยได้รู้จักกับ
ตลาดนัดกลางคืนใช่มั้ยในกรุงเทพฯนะคะแต่
นักเรียนไม่ต้องกังวลนะคะตอนนี้นักเรียน
เปิด Google เข้าไปตลาดนัดกลางคืนมีที่
ไหนโอ้โหสะดวกสบายค่ะนักเรียนเนี่ยดู GPS
ได้เลยนะคะหรือไม่ก็บอกแท็กซี่ค่ะใช่นะคะ
โอเคงั้นวันนี้เราลาทุกๆคนไปก่อนนะคะ
สวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะพบกันใหม่ค่ะ